الاقتصاد سلاح يهدد ظهر اميركا هنا فيما
يعرف بفنائها الخلفي امريكا اللاتينيه حيث
لايران وروسيا واخيرا الصين صولات وجولات
اقتصاديه لا تنتهي ظاهرها الدعم وباطنها
تعزيز النفود
تقرير جورنال شرح كيف استطاعت هذه الدول
تهديد عرش امريكا
بتحركاتها في جاراتها اللاتينيه البدايه
من موسكو حيث اشارت الصحيفه الى انها عززت
من وجودها في كوبا منذ نحو 60 عاما مضت
بدعمها الاقتصاد الكوبي الا ان كل ما عملت
عليه يبدو انه فقد اهميته مقابل جهود
الصين التقرير كشف ان التجاره الصينيه مع
امريكا اللاتينيه ومنطقه البحر الكاريبي
ارتفعت من 18 مليار دولار في عام 2002 الى
450 مليار دولار بعد عشرين عاما متوقعا
وصول هذه التجاره الى 700 مليار دولار
بحلول عام 2035 سواء في انشطه البنى
التحتيه او غيرها الا ان الابرز هو منحها
احدى عشره منشاه او اكثر في خمس دول في
المنطقه قدرات تتبع ومراقبه متطوره
وامالها في التوسع
اما ايران فرئيسها ابراهيم رئيسي هو على
ارض فنزويلا بالفعل حيث وقع اتفاقيات
ثنائيه لتوسيع التعاون وزياده التجاره
الثنائيه لتصل قيمتها الى 20 مليار دولار
عدا عن دول اخرى
التقارير الغربيه تعتبرت ان رد فعل امريكا
حول الاخبار التي تفيد بان الصين عرضت على
كوبا مليارات الدولارات مقابل بناء منشاه
استخباراتيه متطوره هو رد فعل سلبي وانها
منحت لخصومها مفاتيح ابواب جيرانها
ليخرجوا من رحم اقتصادات متهالكه فرص
تاريخيه ما سيقوض قدره اميركا مستقبلا